foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing the probability of whether or
not Santa's elves have any relation to
the house elves that appear throughout
Harry Potter as I'm sure you can
appreciate this is a somewhat
complicated topic first of all there's
an absurd amount of Elven law that has
existed over the centuries of course the
elves that are rumored to reside in the
North Pole with Jolly Old Saint Nick are
just one of many because of course elves
are a common component of just about any
Fantastical realm created by novelists
one really doesn't have to think very
hard or for very long to come up with a
list of books and movies that include
this magical species Lord of the Rings
The Witcher these are just a couple of
the most popular and commonly known
series and universes that include an
Elven people so why compare the house
elves of Harry Potter with the Santa
Claus's elves well in my opinion there
are just one too many similarities
between these two sets of elves to
ignore if we are ready to accept that
both these creatures exist within the
same universe which I assume we are
since Christmas is acknowledged by the
characters of Harry Potter throughout
the books and films and in a world where
magical beings clearly exist it'd be
rather ridiculous to rule out that Santa
also exists so if we are ready to accept
that both sets of elves exist in the
same universe then it's only logical to
assume that they are related however
distantly let's start with the obvious
since we're not simply comparing these
two Elven populations in the video we're
actually looking to uncover whether or
not they are indeed related linked or
what have you that means that we must
first establish how Santa the North Pole
and his elves would fit into the Harry
Potter universe and Wizarding World as a
whole well to begin with what's most
obvious to me is that Santa is a wizard
yes I said it please don't come after me
too harshly in the comments I mean Saint
Nick is pretty much the most obvious and
widely known not to mention most widely
accepted example of a magical being
right for starters Islip for centuries
something only wizard kind is known to
do Among Us humanoid beings Zucker of
all he has a Long White Beard okay no
I'm only joking although if you really
think about it all of the most
well-known Wizards have had long white
beards Albus Dumbledore Merlin there
just might be something there no anyway
then there's the fact that he's able to
deliver gifts to each and every child on
Earth despite a drastic increase in
population over the last few decades we
currently have 8 billion people on Earth
with an estimated 2 billion of those
being children between the ages of zero
and 14. so how could one man deliver
gifts to 2 billion children in one night
it's clearly the work of magic I'm sure
he's got the whole different time zones
thing on his side so he's got an
extended night situation going on but
how else would he visit the home of each
and every child around the globe within
such a constrained timeline say it with
me now magic and not just any magic
powerful magic and since Santa himself
is not an elf that leaves the only
possible explanation for his abilities
that he is indeed a wizard right so once
you're able to clearly draw the line
between the magic of Santa Claus and the
Wizarding Community as we know it from
the Harry Potter Universe it's not
unreasonable to come to other
connections between the two worlds let's
start with what we know in terms of the
house elves from Harry Potter throughout
the series we come to know about the
existence of ourselves first introduced
by way of the atypical house elf Dobby
in the Chamber of Secrets in most cases
ourselves are bound to serve one family
of witches and wizards tied to their
servitude by way of a magical contract
these contracts require them to act in
the best interest of their masters
whatever the cost and the contracts are
unbreakable unless a member of The
Wizarding family whom the elf serves
bestows or gifts an item of clothing a
upon or two their elf through our
acquaintance with a couple specific
elves namely Dobby originally enslaved
by the Malfoy family it's also revealed
that even the elves who become free
maintain a rather astounding and by all
accounts unintentional sense of Duty
towards their former Masters for example
Dobby despite having no love for the
malfoys causes himself harm when he
speaks ill of his former Masters
actions such as theirs make it quite
obvious but at least to me that there's
more at work here than just a magically
binding contract it brings to light the
question of whether or not these house
elves have been bred to be dutiful
obedient servants a theory further
supported by the fact there is only ever
one house elf per Wizarding family
suggesting that in order to continue
their species house elves would need to
be intentionally brought together to
mate a rather disturbing thought if you
ask me in any case if this is a subject
that interests you I highly recommend
you check out my previous video on the
subject why do elves serve wizard kind
if they're so powerful
by contrast what does popular culture
long-standing myths and many a legend
tell us about the elves that reside
alongside Santa Claus up in the North
Pole well to start we know that they all
serve Santa in his efforts to make toys
for the children of the world seems
innocent enough however many depictions
of Santa and the elves show the elves
also caring for Mrs Claus's needs this
makes it rather unclear as to whether
the elves are responsible for tasks such
as making Santa Claus's meals and
tending to his housekeeping throughout
the year in the same way house elves do
for the Wizarding Community this also
brings up the elves personal interests
are they working to serve Santa against
their will operating as the house elves
do under a magically binding contract
that forces them to make toys and serve
Saint Nick or are they more like
cheerful volunteers who are there by
choice because they simply want to fill
the world with joy and help make
children smile and with questions like
these it's hard not to wonder if these
elves are the same type of creatures as
the house elves are they related at all
it seems almost impossible to think that
they have absolutely no relation with
one another and so it is my belief that
these two sets of elves are indeed
related in some if not distant way in my
opinion I think it's rather likely that
they started off as One Tribe of valves
possibly located in the Scandinavian
region of the world because isn't that
where popular law tells us Santa's elves
originated so perhaps there in what is
now known as Finland or Northern Sweden
there was a group of Elven people whose
histories diverged when they met wizard
kind imagine the more cynical docile and
rather cowardly few of this group
decided to align themselves with the
protection of witches and wizards they
moved into their magical homes and
inadvertently began to serve them then
agreed to sign contracts to secure their
positions within the Wizarding Community
only to have their dutiful demeanors
taken advantage of and their rights
slowly Stripped Away another group may
have stayed in the wild eventually
visited by one Saint Nicholas a wizard
unlike the more Sinister magical
families who had visited them before
this wizard spoke of Hope joy and making
the children of the world Happy despite
having very little to offer them and so
a second set of elves were swayed to
join a very different Wizarding home one
in which a man and his wife we assume
Mrs Claus is a witch yes had set up in
the far north away from the Judgment of
the rest of the Wizarding World to build
toys throughout the year and deliver
them to Children one night annually as
populations grew Santa and his elves
would have had to continue to migrate
further north to remain undetected by
other communities until eventually they
reach the North Pole here they have
stayed for centuries working together
harmoniously or otherwise to bring Joy
to the World each and every Christmas
and with that we come to the end of
another video what did you think please
share your thoughts in the comments
below and as always if you enjoyed this
video don't forget to like it and
subscribe to the channel until next time
remember Dobby is a free elf
foreign